why are all the ghosts white that's it
yeah you don't think any slaves have
unfinished business
interesting now because like you know if
you live in like certain gentrified
neighborhoods you can't tell if that
person's a ghost or just a hipster you
don't know some of the clothes these
people are wearing home you people out
there on the bus dressed like Civil War
generals yeah just on the bus and
they're not healthy so you're like
that's a problem
yeah like this guy is scurvy you
shouldn't be translucent mm-hmm what's
up everybody welcome to stupid questions
I'm Krista Stefano aka Krissy the nipple
with me Josh Johnson writer for The
Daily Show's got a great album out
called I like you and he did a half-hour
special last year I do like you
good good kid you got good energy I like
you too appreciate it if you could be
any fruit what kind of fruit would you
be I think I'd be an avocado Wow is that
that is a fruit avocado the seed is like
indestructible you can't destruct that
seed yep why wouldn't be all over me
100% avocado that or like a like an iced
latte like since you asked me a fruit
I'm gonna say a fruit sushi oh my god
yeah
white girls love sushi also whole
countries love sushi which one of your
relatives would you find that the
hardest to perform stand up in front of
my uncle my uncle's like never had a
good job right yeah you could tell he's
never had a good job because he like
never answers with like one or two words
straight up when you ask of what he does
like he's like well you got to know it's
like no no just tell me what you have an
electrician I straight up was asking
about I was like how you been what you
been up to he's like well you like
Turkey right I'm like no just tell me
now it turns out turkeys can't even
breathe naturally right if someone has
to jerk turkeys off he was like a turkey
jerker look you you want this given you
got come to me
what is something everybody looks stupid
doing throwing up yeah I've never seen
like I throw up yeah I ever seen someone
good yeah no I mean it's always like
that's somebody who like throws up what
they see people throw up
oh yeah hilarious okay so I have a
friend that was in Chicago and like my
buddy and I would just stand next to him
I'd be like hey do you guys what a pole
yeah any bug what are you doing I really
nothing and we only ever did it was
because we felt so bad about it once it
actually happened it's like hooking the
bear right and then he actually threw up
we're like oh we gotta like take care of
him and what we do on this show is you
answer the stupid questions you get a
stupid gift so I got you a gift what
this is it's a turtleneck bib because
you have like a joke and you have like
bitch hands or something so we figured
that this just encompasses a person who
says that he can't choke someone out
sexually I never said that I
it's a turtleneck oh no it looks
completely useless thank you do you like
the gifts in that no I don't like the
gift at all and you said I have bitch
hands put it on oh yeah then why is
there big on the back what is it so you
got to clean it like a bad porn outfit
hey people are into that
no no one is into this
you